[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: The COVID-19 pandemic
has affected people's health,
finances, and daily lives.
They are increasingly turning
to governments, health care
organizations, and other
businesses for information
using online and phone support.
This sudden, unprecedented
customer demand
is overwhelming customer
support resources.
In this video, we will walk
you through a rapid response
virtual agent solution, which
is built using a template
that we've open sourced.
This to help you address
immediate customer inquiries
and relieve pressure from
your contact centers.
Let's take a look.
Here's a web-based example.
Let's say a user is looking
to know more about COVID-19
and how it spreads.
They can just click on
the suggestion bubbles
like, "What is COVID-19?"
or "How does it spread?"
And it responds accordingly
based on WHO and CDC
recommendations.
If the user wants to
get a screening done,
they can just click on
the Start Screening button
and enter straight
into screening.
The flow here will depend
on the user selection,
but let's say none
of those apply.
They select No and are presented
with some more symptoms.
Let's say they are experiencing
signs of low blood pressure
and indicate Yes
in this response.
The screening indicates
that they should
seek medical help immediately.
Let's take an example
of a user whose
situation is not this serious.
They start the
screening process,
don't have any serious
life-threatening symptoms,
but are experiencing some cough
and minor shortness in breath.
The screening now gets deeper
into their travel history,
where they have been
in the last 14 days,
and then verifies their age
to suggest a course of action,
or other resources like how
to manage COVID at home.
If you would like to customize
a solution with your own web UI
to match with your brand,
you can absolutely do that.
Here's an example.
Let's say a user is interested
in knowing the number of cases
in the United States.
They can select the auto
suggestion and get a response.
They can also type
their question.
Say they are concerned
about receiving packages.
Is it safe to receive packages?
The responses are coming
from the same agent.
It just has a custom UI now.
If you have users who may want
to call in through the phone
to ask some questions and
to get screening done,
you can easily assign
a phone number.
We have one assigned here.
Let's call.
BOT: Hello.
I am the COVID-19
Rapid Response Bot.
You can ask me questions
related to COVID-19
and I will provide some answers
based on publicly available
information.
Disclaimer, I do not provide
medical advice, diagnosis,
or treatment.
If you are experiencing a
life-threatening emergency,
call 9-1-1.
How can I help?
SPEAKER: What is the difference
between flu and coronavirus?
BOT: A COVID-19 infection has
the same signs and symptoms
as the common cold, and you
can only differentiate them
through laboratory testing
to determine the virus type.
SPEAKER: Is the virus airborne?
BOT: Studies to date
suggest that the virus that
causes COVID-19 is mainly
transmitted through contact
with respiratory droplets
rather than through the air.
SPEAKER: As you saw,
the open source template
is pre-trained with common
COVID-19-related answers
and triage screener.
You can enhance and update the
experience as often as needed
through dialogue flow.
Please refer to our
documentation for a quick guide
to get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]